solaris a man who's in front of the Sun
sky gazers travel from across the world
to the Isle of Lewis
to see one of nature's most majestic
sites
a total eclipse is a rare phenomenon and
here in the Outer Hebrides where there
was ninety-eight percent coverage the
excitement was palpable oh it's a quite
a big occasion spring equinox solar
eclipse new moon super new moon why not
it's a special place it's a special time
of the year at Bryan yes we're just
delighted to be here almost there
fantastic we travel the distance or they
were quite happy it's supposed to work
we get a shadow and behind it it's a
nice one office around eggs by social
occasions awesome that's why they can
restore the rightful here that's the
real reason let's get it over to me
let's give this big guy a chance to see
it as well only a few places would
experience a total eclipse and magical
moments of complete coverage but in the
Faroe Islands and Sal bar in Norway the
conditions were less than perfect with
intermittent cloud you could just make
out the moon sliding almost
imperceptibly across the Sun the diurnal
certainty of life disrupted swallowed
one chunk at a time
an eerie Twilight's then fell across the
lands birdsong was silenced by the
crepuscular darkness and the temperature
dropped by a few degrees and for just a
few minutes the faint circling light of
the Sun's corona glow dimly behind a
lunar plots
the moon's shadow now the total the
umbral part of the moon shadow the very
center of the moon shadow now passing
right over that tiny island of svalbard
off the coast of norway a principality
of norway where hundreds or if not
thousands of people have gathered and
braved the cold to see this experience
the next time anyone will be able to see
anything like this on the surface of the
earth will be in 2017 and they're going
to need to go over to America to get a
view we can actually see a glimpse of it
we've just got a little break in the
cloud and we have got just the very tail
end of totality the Sun is now poking
through so now we're seeing a bright
flash of light from the Sun coming
through the valleys on the moon the
moon's rugged surface they're allowing
light to spill through a beautiful
diamond ring here we see a ring of light
that's very faint and one big flash on
one side like a like a lovely engagement
ring in the sky I enjoyed it was nice to
be part of it and there was one moment
where the shadows were quite dramatic
and that was a nice or moment I thought
that was incredible I came up from ken's
as well and it was the colors at the
time of the Eclipse and also the fact is
the spring equinox today so it really
was that balance between everything it
was absolutely incredible the Eclipse is
a divine site and across Britain
schoolchildren gazed in wonder at the
skies their tiny eyes protected by
special glasses they'd made during class
this is so important to them this is an
extracurricular this is central to their
education its what what a wonderful
opportunity for them this eclipse is a
solar eclipse or what happens is the
moon goes in front of the Sun so where
we are now we will get about a few bit
of darkness obviously none of us has
ever seen it before because as we said
the last one was in 1999's it is easy to
see why the ancients were fascinated and
terrified by this celestial events
in ancient China it was thought a dragon
was devouring the Sun the Greeks
believed the gods were angry and death
and destruction was on its way it's
worth remembering that when the moon
formed about three and a half billion to
four billion years ago which is much
closer to the earth it used to orbit the
Earth every six hours it would have been
an enormous object in the sky it's been
receding at a rate of well now about 4
centimeters every year thousands of
years later in Greenwich science and
rationalism have replaced superstition
hundreds of amateur astronomers lined
out to analyze the Eclipse tablets and
telescopes at the ready there are a few
mechanisms in place right now today on
any other day the moon is normally too
high or too low compared to the Sun I
won't block the Sun out in any way but
today we're lucky enough to be in the
shadow of the moon for about two hours
all together that wonderful ratio of
distance and size is just something we
don't experience anywhere else in the
solar system I said have this is quite
special and it's something that as well
we had rely on the moon being a little
bit closer at the moment as well which
means for those folks of me faroe
islands and spybot islands getting to
have the the whole disk of the Sun
covered across much of Europe North
Africa and the Middle East life stopped
and I swivel that to the heavens to
witness the event the event has a
special significance to Egypt and in
particular to the place we are into in
the in the pyramids area the Shah the
son is a God in the in the ancient
Egyptian culture and we can see several
places throughout Egypt we can see the
lineup of the of the Sun rise and the
sunset with with the dimples so we can
see a very interesting link between the
Sun and the ancient Egyptian culture
on the continent offices empty as
workers abandoned their desks this was
too special to miss
but whilst there was excitement there
was also disappointments blankets of
cloud eclipse the Eclipse in many places
spoiling one of nature's most unusual
sites in areas though with a clear view
it was spectacular a near total eclipse
like this will not bless the skies above
Britain again until 2020 six